hola desde montreal un gran abrazo y
saludo a todos los que nos están
escuchando y nos están viendo en este
momento desde facebook que youtube y
también desde nuestro sitio web eres en
este punto o sea me acompañan hoy en el
programa leonardo gimeno pablo gómez
barrios paloma martínez y tenemos un
invitado o se llama juan miguel hidalgo
pero él dice que se llama en realidad
jm hidalgo ya vamos a estar conversando
con jm hidalgo cómo están ustedes están
preparándose para esta anunciada
canícula que se viene este fin de semana
y que justamente se está festejando
además el día de canadá este calor que
dicen que va a ser insoportable ustedes
creen en eso para menos el calor es
insoportable
después me cada vez que veo eso me meto
en alguna de las redes sociales y miro
un vídeo compartido por mí entre
septiembre y
y abril
no claro es que además acá en canadá a
decir 32 grados 33 grados de que se es
mucho para los canadienses pero para
nosotros que venimos de los calores pues
me imagino aquí tenemos un dominicano
que tiene calor todo el año es bueno yo
soy de barranquilla
hace 38 grados a la sombra diariamente
así y religiosamente entonces estoy
esperando ansioso esa famosa que está
hablando que se está anunciando en los
diarios no salió están advirtiendo hay
advertencia lo estaba leyendo en el
sitio de civis y radio canadá entonces
es dice caramba dónde cuánto estamos
hablando no es que dicen que la gente
sobre todo los que son más vulnerables
son los niños y los ancianos y cómo es
el día de canadá el domingo y todo va a
estar cerrado tienen miedo que no haya
suficientes lugares aves con aire
acondicionado para que las alas son
exactamente a la zona todo cerrado
porque justamente es el día de canadá
están viendo si se quedan las piscinas
solas para los niños solos que sí
estarían cerradas por el día de canadá
bueno muy bien bueno aparte de eso hay
que decir que este fin de semana aparte
de ser el día de canadá año del primero
de julio que se festeja en todo el país
también es un día muy particular para
méxico y no sólo el domingo sino también
el lunes méxico va a estar en todos los
titulares por dos razones ustedes saben
muy bien son las elecciones el perejil
ideal es el día de canadá y el lunes
méxico juega con sabrá si entra brasil
qué pena que la ciudad
quería con ser mejores queríamos ser
mejores para no jugar contra brasil pero
no pudimos venir por tanto habían
comenzado muy bien pero qué mal
terminaron los procesaron contra los
daneses pero
y en contra los suecos yo no sé pero
como algunos ven el lado positivo es
dicen que un país latinoamericano va a
pasar a la próxima ronda sí ya sea
brasil o méxico uno de los dos va a
pasar
uruguay uruguay y argentina
[Música]
lo que sí sé es que los franceses tiene
mucho miedo eso me interesa veamos sí
pero mejor es decir que tienen miedo
pero tienen un excelente equino eso
ningún problema pero salieron los dos
defensores centrales a decir no hay que
tener en cuenta que embate no es ni
messi ni ronaldo que messi se despertó
que uno el sabor que están con el ánimo
alto
el director técnico salió a decir que es
imprevisible con la argentina siempre
pueda sorpresas y que hay que tenerle
muchísimo respeto o sea ese tipo de
mágico lógico el tema no se convierte ya
en algo psicológico pero el experto en
deportes de radio canadá robert foster
dijo que francia puede no pasar esto
está jugando mal dice que no están
jugando en equipo yo estoy de acuerdo
con estos franceses están de acuerdo con
qué piensan ustedes es la primera vez
que se aplica este fair play que piensan
ustedes que permitió que japón por
ejemplo se clasifique que se ponga de
senegal
el fair play a lo que se hacía antes que
era por la ubicación en el ranking de la
afa por ejemplo se hizo eso
y me parece horrible porque si la nación
no tuvo muchos partidos internacionales
no sumó puntos entonces queda fuera es
una locura el cielo parece eso es mejor
que la última posibilidad que es si
estaban iguales en fair play sorteo la
moneda lo que siento es que ahora en el
proxy no lo que quería decir alguien
pues un buen mensaje es decir estás
enviando el mensaje de que hay que jugar
bien para pasar a la siguiente ronda no
tienes que hacer demasiadas faltas sin
embargo claro que hay que pensar toda la
parte de la subjetividad de los árbitros
del juego mismo hay un periodista
argentino que publicó en el 'new york
times' y eso lo leí hoy y realmente me
llamó la atención hablando del fair play
que dice que no es fair play dice
muchísimas cosas en se llama martín
caparrós
el 'fair play' es una idea que tuvieron
los ingleses hace siglo y medio cuando
el deporte la cosa de estudiantes ricos
que las iban de caballeros porque lo
practicaban entre ellos entre caballeros
mientras se cargaban a cuánto indio o
africano o proletario fuera menester
para darle diamantes o victorias a la
reina y demás
por supuesto hay muchas cosas en este
artículo pero me pareció interesante no
sabía que fue inventado por los ingleses
también los ingleses en el sentido de
que no se golpean tanto
pero lo que siempre no bebe el deporte
es el deporte además en uno benja que
necesitaba los desempeñen pero nadie
sale bueno salvo las conmociones
cerebrales y muchos heridos
en méxico estuvimos diciendo va a haber
elecciones hemos conversado mucho sobre
de este tema en radio canadá
internacional y los resultados dicen que
pues le dan ventaja a andrés manuel
lópez obrador con el 51% de las
intenciones de voto
que las encuestadoras se equivoquen pero
por lo menos tres de las más importantes
entonces el diario reforma el financiero
y
no hay otra
una ventaja de más de 20
nadie puede alcanzar pero qué desafíos
tendrá lópez obrador lo que dice la una
vez que los muy grandes tiene desafíos
muy grandes porque méxico está muy
dividido es un país muy dividido creo
que es la primera vez en la que yo
siento una división muy profunda entre
las opiniones de la gente además le han
hecho una guerra bastante sucia a lópez
obrador en los medios sociales
particularmente pero también medios
grandes entonces tendrá que tendrá la el
gran desafío de unificar a los mexicanos
ricos de los mexicanos menos ricos o
pobres porque yo creo que la división
fundamental se ve ahí por un lado y por
otro lado yo creo que sí yo creo que el
primer desafío es que la gente salga a
votar el 1º de julio porque
efectivamente las intenciones de voto
como ganador pero hay que ver la gente
tiene que salir a votar en mexico hay
una gran tendencia a no presentarse a la
hora de hacerlo aunque sea obligatorio
porque oficialmente tienes la obligación
de presentarte ahora sé que los jóvenes
van a votar no es lo que están diciendo
que son jóvenes que no han vivido la
época famosa gloriosa del pri y que en
este momento el pri está muy relacionado
con todo lo que es corrupción en méxico
y bueno lópez obrador va a tener que
hacer enfrentar pues el tema de la
corrupción en méxico empiezo serio y
además de sido su caballo de batalla no
siempre ha llevado adelante ese charco
él armó su campaña prometiendo combatir
la corrupción y la violencia en méxico
está en el año pasado dice que hubo más
de 25 mil asesinatos en mexico no
entonces es tiene muchísimo tiene
muchísimo por delante en el sentido de
calmar los ánimos calmar la violencia
encontrar un equilibrio porque la guerra
está en todo lo que da la guerra al
interior de méxico contra el
narcotráfico comenzó en el 2006
y no ha parado y las muero de los
resultados encontrar otra manera de
enfrentar al narcotráfico en méxico y
por otro lado tiene que encontrar
también como como decía yo un camino
para apaciguar los ánimos ante la gente
para no sentir esas divisiones para
demostrar lo que me puede gobernar y
ahora de todos exacto exactamente y
además después pues me imagino que el
otro gran desafío que tiene lópez
obrador es el tlcan el tratado de libre
comercio norteamericano que es lo que él
dice ahora es que hay que negociar lo
que es lo importante que estén los tres
tiene un poco méxico en estos momentos
está más cerca de canadá que de eeuu
justamente por los ataques del
presidente trump a hacia canadá y hacia
eeuu
la diferencia es que lo que dijo es
también en la campaña lópez obrador era
que negociar con eeuu y para no agachar
la cabeza precisamente hay que ver va a
tener dificultades me imagino en
negociar y hacer frente a la agresividad
que tiene sobre todo verbal y otra el
presidente estadounidense lo que tiene
que demostrarle también a los
inversionistas es que méxico no tiene la
intención
si él es presidente de desafinar se
completamente los acuerdos comerciales
las campañas mienten
sobre todo ese miedo por la izquierda
ese miedo que le costó las elecciones a
gustavo petro en colombia comienza con
el cuento de que el castrochavismo va a
llevar a la miseria
y de todas maneras pues hace más de 200
años desde la vida republicana y
refiriéndome a colombia que son las
derechas las que han gobernado el país y
si hay miseria en el país es justamente
debido a los gobiernos de derecha que ha
habido desde hace más de 200 años
entonces de repente hay un candidato de
izquierda y como está ese miedo que han
inculcado que no se vuelva a colombia lo
que es lo que se volvió venezuela o cuba
méxico también tienen
el mismo miedo a lo extraño digo no sé
si eso lo conoces mejor voz al tema es
que en colombia se haya votado a un
presidente que prometió revisar los
acuerdos de paz eso es lo más difícil de
comprender cuando han vivido tantos años
en violencia ero no se te olvide no se
te olvide que cuando se votaron cuando
se firmaron los acuerdos de paz en la
habana en colombia el acuerdo de paz con
la guerrilla colombiana se sometió a
referéndum
ss ese acuerdo de paz y fue rechazado
por la población
entonces como usted explica que un país
que llevaba más de 50 años
y grande a la guerrilla no en américa la
izquierda que pero no claro entonces y
el rechazo por la izquierda de embargo
lópez obrador esta maestra
ojo no es lo mismo que colombia
no es lo mismo
salvo que haya una catástrofe que uno no
puede entender
puede suceder porque la gente puede
decidir que no se presenta porque
también hubo campañas de miedo que
estuvieron circulando y si tomas en
cuenta el número de candidatos que han
muerto por lo menos 50 como comprobados
y periodista entre los cuales uno hace
dos días y periodos estas veces y
periodistas entonces entre candidatos y
periodistas muertos durante esta campaña
electoral presidencial en méxico la
gente tiene miedo que haya algo
horroroso que suceda cuando se presenten
en las casillas a votar yo no creo
méxico tiene como quiera un sistema
electoral bastante complejo y bastante
bien organizado y lo han puesto en
marcha y lo haya tenido sus errores a
través de la historia pero creo que está
bien sólido entonces no creo que haya
una catástrofe claro que ese es mi punto
de vista desde aclaro no seguro seguro
uno lo está viendo de lejos y está según
las informaciones que uno tiene la
tercera casa de encuesta de la que le
hablaba en mí
quedan a lópez obrador como ganador es
parametría es el instituto de
investigación estratégica análisis de
opinión y mercado de la reforma el
financiero y parametría que son son
importantes son el organismo encaja a
lópez obrador eso decimos méxico va a
ser noticia entonces me imagino que el
domingo se van a conocer los resultados
y el lunes se va a conocer los
resultados del partido en todas las
bocas
ahora tenemos como dijimos al principio
invitado juan miguel hidalgo conocido
como jm hidalgo es un comunicador es un
antiguo allende del oyente de la corta
de de la onda corta de radio canadá
internacional nos escuchaba allá en
república dominicana está aquí de paseo
de turista en canadá por eso lo
invitamos también a venir a conversar
con nosotros y hay algo que tengo que
decir acá es que usted batió un récord
mundial en república dominicana
de permanencia en radio hablando por 80
horas sin interrupción en el año
entonces todas las palabras de 80 horas
son casi cuatro días como iniciamos
iniciamos un viernes a las 7 de la
mañana y concluimos el lunes a las 3 de
la tarde con el radiotón si sin dormir
sin parar micrófono abierto todo el
tiempo y ahí realizamos ese maratón que
realmente eran 80 programas yo tenía 80
guiones por hora un guión por hora y
entonces lo realizamos muy muy
coherentemente evidentemente en algunos
momentos nos dio sueño debilidad
mira que no comimos porque porque
establece dormir exactamente en la
sangre se dirige directamente al
estómago entonces te dejé el cerebro con
menos aire se vuelve entonces
bueno muchos muchos líquidos agua el
agua es lo principal
80 la mujer teme bueno en principio en
los años en la década de los 70 cuando
yo escuchaba radio canadá internacional
que de eso vamos a hablar y hubo una
persona que realizó una hazaña de durar
una semana y pico en una cabina de radio
otro duró más de 15 o 20 días dentro de
una cabina pero no hablando es decir
durar ese tiempo en la cabina cada media
hora
decía el tiempo la hora presentaba un
disco y luego un dijo que ponía la
música y después media hora después
decía lo mismo que verificaba que nacía
rampa sí pero yo dije que una semana en
una cabina de radio no es una gran
osadía
hay personas que duran 30 años en una
celda es nada no salen entonces el hecho
era romper el récord en el sentido de
hablar cuál era la capacidad del ser
humano de durar hablando cuánto tiempo
no lo sabíamos al día de hoy realmente
nos rompimos un récord establecimos un
récord porque hasta el día de hoy ni
nadie lo ha intentado y anteriormente
tampoco nadie lo que hicieron es único
no tienen todavía no competencia no es
que usted estuvo 80 horas pero después
quería seguir hablando y lo tuvieron que
parar fueron que fueron 80 horas de
transmisión porque fue por una estación
de radio y al final el 90% de las
emisoras de radio de la república
dominicana entraron en cadena pero
fueron 80 horas de transmisión realmente
yo duré despierto algunas 89 o 90 horas
despierto totalmente ciertamente sueño
el momento al momento de tu estar
leyendo y saber que te están escuchando
sobre todo uno que les gusta esto de la
comunicación y la locución uno uno se
alimenta y los ánimo surgen además el
gran reto la cabina siempre estuvo llena
de gente siempre a toda hora de la
madrugada no importaba de donde fuera
llegaban de todas partes del país
y eso nos comprometía a más que
compromiso nos alentaba exactamente no
nos daba mucho más ánimo y fuimos
creciendo y realmente cuando concluir
las 80 horas quería seguir aunque sean
dos horas más que ya tenía la adrenalina
también
hay otro récord sí sí pero se lo
realizamos en nuestra comunidad
un poco de los jóvenes jóvenes cuatro
jóvenes que participaron o no el récord
de el mango más grande del mundo
el mango
no sabía que le va a crear curiosidad
ahora mismo nuestros famosos peloteros
hablo mucho del power no tiene que ver
con el plátano es un alimento es el
plátano verde majado como si fuera un
puré de plátano pisado exactamente pero
hervido plátano hervido como si fuera un
puré de plátano entonces se le llama
mango ese es una muy muy muy dominicano
creo que es la comida más dominicana por
ser la más sencilla por ser fruto
también de circunstancias sociales en un
momento en que en que nació esto y por
el gusto luego de la población incluso
de extranjero que le ha gustado mucho
este este plato que se come más en el
desayuno y en la cena acompañado de ese
arreglo y digo esto porque tú que eres
de colombia 20 américa
o en pocos países se comía ya se come el
plátano verde nosotros siempre hemos
comido el plátano el plátano verde
quiere decir que no es maduro se llama
verde color verde pero es maduro no no
no
no llega
en méxico se come el plátano de estos
que son grandes en el platero los fritos
frito
frito pero cuando está maduro mientras
que en otras regiones como en república
dominicana se come cuando todavía está
verde el plátano no les hace mal no les
causa en argentina
nosotros sólo tenemos la banana
siles y tuviesen la oportunidad para mí
es exótico decir es como la guayaba
plata
bueno pero los culinarios siempre está
presente en todas las conversaciones
me gustaría brindarle pero sabes que se
se prepara también en colombia en la
costa colombiana pero el plátano verde
nosotros lo echamos en los sancochos en
la sopa esta grandota que hacemos se le
echa plátanos verón el puchero y a veces
allá se conoce como un sancocho también
es una sopa que se decía que el plátano
frito entonces en sudamérica le llaman
pata con su la manera de patoruzú caro
también entonces en república dominicana
lo hacemos como frito verde más cortito
las pajaritas le decimos frito verde o
tostón
eso también perú entonces el otro plato
que se hace con el otro plato que se
hace con plátano verde es el mofongo
tiene un origen entre cuba república
república dominicana
es plátano verde y medio frito medio
asado sobre todo asado el mondongo bueno
se puede acompañar
yo comí un plátano de esos bebés pero no
verdes sino maduros
[Risas]
al estilo colombiano lo ponen en el
asador y se comen las grasas se comen
cuba con los frijoles
y la banana cortada y frita es lo mismo
verdad es todo centroamérica y el caribe
sí porque en el sur de méxico en el sur
de méxico más cerca de américa central
en la américa hacen en méxico la parte
centro
de méxico al contrario si méxico tiene
una parte en américa del norte una parte
en américa central geográfica dos pies
dos pies es que todo esto viene acá
razón de que dijimos que hicimos un otro
récord que fue el mango más grande del
mundo agua que bajaron que participó en
la preparación cerca de dos mil personas
fue muy grata consumirlo otras tantas
ese es el armani del plátano estuvimos
hablando al menos estuvimos hablando de
un mango de un puré de plátano para que
la gente mango para que la gente busque
que se llama mango muy bien estaba hecho
con 54.000 plata
[Música]
los plátanos repubblica
en boca y en el país hay mucho más plata
había una mesa de una extensión de por
lo menos 100 metros de largo
más o menos metros de largo
sí bueno está registrado en la prensa
nacional en los medios y todo eso pero
no en guinness porque tienes es una
empresa privada y no sabes ni siquiera
lo que era el mango y no entendieron el
mango y no lo uses jodieron o sea no lo
muero revistas pero ya para ellos ahora
juan miguel aquí tengo mensajes que nos
llegan a nuestra creación del facebook
si ese jesús cardona dice les invitamos
a que informen del desarrollo de las
elecciones en méxico y nos manda bueno
esos datos emilio di stéfano s gracias
leo en realidad al equipo muy buen
programa daniel campo line en argentina
dice tenemos el choripán
[Risas]
en serio tengo hambre es bueno
brenda tristán dice o la paloma me
encanta escucharte y más sonreír
y esos son los mensajes que tenemos muy
bien en el nuestro face muy bien
bueno o jm
ahora hablemos un poco de su experiencia
como radioescucha de la onda corta y
cuando nos escuchaba un poco al radio
canadá internacional cuando era eso
estamos hablando precisamente de la
década de los 70 y mediados de los 70 en
adelante continuamos pero ya con menos
frecuencia porque comenzamos nuestra
labor profesional también en los medios
y para nosotros era un sueño venir aquí
venir a radio canadá internacional
conocerle ver me hubiese gustado llegar
en el momento en que todavía existían
las transmisiones con un taco abr ondas
cortas y entonces ver los transmisores
ver el lugar donde estaban las antenas
que yo sé que era una maravilla en ese
entonces pero en mi hombro estaban
vendidos y conocer precisamente todas
estas dependencias cómo era que ustedes
ustedes funcionaban internamente para
poder producir en aquel entonces creo
que era como 10 o 12 idiomas que
transmitía radio canadá internacional
y uno siempre se preguntaba cómo era eso
cómo se hacía recordemos que hace en la
década de los 70 yo tenía algunos
15 años 14 13 años de edad
entonces era una gran era una gran
incertidumbre uno empezó entonces a
estudiar de qué eran las ondas cortas
cómo llegaban las emisoras de tan lejos
podían llegar a nuestro país a nuestra
isla y así uno conocido todos yo tengo
calcomanías de radio canadá
internacional tengo banderines tengo la
tarjeta de la eso es un tesoro lo tengo
haya guardado y tengo de varias
estaciones también de onda corta radio
francia radio france internacional radio
de vela la radio nederland que era una
de las de las favoritas también junto
con radio canadá y que entonces uno se
fue alimentando también de las
informaciones de ustedes los locutores
escucharon no es lo mismo escuchar un
locutor por ejemplo de república
dominicana que escuchar un locutor de
una emisora internacional entonces
porque en las estaciones locales son muy
coloquiales entonces aquí es más formal
hay un guión hay un punto de partida y
hay un punto de llegada en un espacio
allí no es allí tú entras te hablas te
comenzaste y termino como termine no hay
objetivo era muy formal hasta que
hablamos del mango
siempre hay una columna vertebral
entonces uno puede salirse pero vuelve
pero la mayoría de los programas además
de que la radio sobre todo tengo que
hablar del caribe no
es muy alegre más musical que hablada en
las últimas décadas es cuando se ha
puesto de moda los stock show en la
radio pero anteriormente era todo música
todo música mucho más música tropical
más que música clásica más que música
instrumental existía en estaciones de
radio como en otros países pero más la
música del día dijeron entonces al
escuchar la radio canadá uno escuchaba
otro tipo de música encontraba otros
tipos de producciones ya uno le empezaba
a gustar la radio comenzaba entonces a
trabajar en ella empezamos grabando
anuncios de películas y todo esto y
reportábamos incluso aquí en radio
canadá la transmisión es a través con el
código simplemente para saber la calidad
del audio
interferencia tolerancia apertura como
protuberancias y perturbar sin
perturbación turbación y lado no me
recuerdo el lado que enfoca nada
digamos que usted se dedicó a los medios
un poquitico también gracias a 30
naciones claro que sí
entre otras no la uno por supuesto
y en las locales también pero pero era
el punto o el objetivo número uno era la
radio canadá emisora internacional ver
llegar conocer los diferentes estudio en
esa época estaba hablando de la década
de los 70 los estudios de grabaciones de
las emisoras de radio de república
dominicana ni parecerse a lo que aquí
existía en ese momento las mismas
transmisiones de los equipos de
transmisión el equipo técnico el equipo
humano
todo eso en esa época en república
dominicana no existía y hoy existe un
poquito nada más no tanto pero de ahí
comenzamos a trabajar si radio lo vamos
a volver en unos segundos entonces con
jm que es me gustaría saber un poco
también su a su impresión de esta
primera visita tal vez aquí en canadá a
ver qué es lo que recorrió hasta ahora
nosotros vamos a ir un poco porque no
nos queda mucho tiempo vamos a conversar
los temas destacados esta semana paloma
estás hablando de discapacidad y de
interactuar con los demás a partir de
nuestra diferencia e identidad y es un
coloquio que tuvo lugar en el oeste
canadiense en la ciudad de winnipeg en
particular organizado por la universidad
de saint boniface que la universidad
francófona de esa de esa ciudad es en
manitoba en este momento de manny
exactamente y fue organizado por una
argentina que se llama maría fernanda
arends en primaria fernanda hansen fue
una de las organizadoras porque tiene
algo de una relación muy especial con la
discapacidad que ella incluso ha querido
que modifiquemos nuestra noción que no
la habíamos discapacidad sino handicap
porque la cndh icap considera las
capacidades de las supervisoras ya que
yo sé exactamente por qué dice que
discapacidad hace pensar que las
personas con alguna diferencia no son
camaró ambiental no son capaces entonces
ella
ha trabajado muy duro porque se cambia
en español pero claro si es difícil pero
bueno hay otras
en francés particularmente para que se
mantenga la palabra andica y no se
utilice la palabra discapacitado
incapacita que es la palabra que tiene
esta connotación negativa si se utiliza
minusválido minusválido también pero si
lo ves para minus exactamente tiene una
connotación también negativa entonces
muy interesante conversación que tuve
con ella y también hablando de ser
discapacidad discapacitada entre
como un inmigrante o incluso como
francófono en esa región porque como
digo trabaja en una universidad
francófona donde es minoría la
francófono y más la entonces interesante
conversar con este especialista 1
encuentro internacional no exactamente
fue un encuentro internacional de los
dos países francófonos y exacto hablando
de discapacidad pues muy interesante
tenemos javi que dice saludos
balón desde ecuador la paloma abrazos
para todos daniel camporini dice la
mejor época de arse y fue en la guerra
fría
bueno fue cuando comenzó durante así no
me está hablando él también dice que la
o es de resumen final
muchísimas gracias muy bien
ya me había olvidado completamente del
significa no salió de la cabeza de uso
todavía según jóvenes son muchachones
eso hablo vos estás presentando destacas
el tema del programa ni na de bolivia y
que está relacionado con la lucha de los
pueblos indígenas por sus derechos qué
pasa con eso fue algo que se llevó a
cabo esa gracia vamos hablando de
internacional ahorita y bueno ese es una
entrevista que hice con edwin arma está
que es el coordinador regional de este
programa ni na de bolivia y él estuvo
invitado cada año que se celebra aquí
desde hace 39 años esta fue la 39
edición
de un programa internacional de
formación en derechos humanos que se da
aquí en montreal por la organización
equitas que es una organización que
trabaja en pos de la educación en
derechos humanos entonces ellos desde
hace 39 años
ofrecen es una formación internacional y
en formación que termina justamente este
viernes 29 de junio
aquí en montreal y en la que este año
participaron
95 personas personas de 52 países es muy
grande es muy grande es grande y bueno
fue interesante conversar con edwin
armata sobre este programa ni na en
bolivia porque entre otras cosas yo le
preguntaba a edwin grecia bueno el hecho
el hecho de que se tenga en bolivia
desde hace casi 11 años o más
un presidente indígena
favorecen los pueblos indígenas ven bien
de tener un presidente indígena y él me
decía que no forzosamente porque se
tenga un pueblo indígena se trabaja en
pos de los derechos de los pueblos
indígenas porque según su punto de vista
en el que el presidente evo morales
también trabaja en pos de otras tiene
otras obligaciones y bueno entonces él
dice tener un presidente llamado
denominado indígena no garantiza el
respeto y el goce de los derechos de las
naciones y pueblos indígenas originarios
porque dentro de los intereses de los
gobiernos hay muchos intereses que no
responden a esas necesidades
es lo que decía textualmente edwin armar
está armada y bueno pues fue interesante
de ver este otro punto de vista de los
pueblos indígenas aquí en esta formación
que se daba en montreal lo que sí es
cierto con bolivia que desde que fue
electo evo morales se acabaron los
golpes
acordémonos nosotros que bolivia tenía
el triste récord de los golpes de estado
cada dos años entonces si hay cosas que
cambiaron con la llegada de evo morales
a bolivia muy interesante gracias pablo
está en herce y net punto o sea vamos a
ir con leonardo ahora que nos va a
hablar como siempre de nuevas
tecnologías pero algo que es para
revolucionar la salud desde la nube con
inteligencia artificial
no es tan complicado si no lo piensa que
lo que están buscando y en este caso es
microsoft la cuestión está del autor de
la labor de este proyecto en realidad
hay un montón de las grandes de
informática que están haciendo lo mismo
pero microsoft se ha puesto en la cabeza
a hacerlo y hacerlo bien y han
contratado ex directores de otras
cuestiones que tienen que ver con la
salud y con la informática para poder
llevarlo a cabo en realidad lo que tiene
que ver es conectar todas
las personas que tengan un 12 clínico o
un expediente clínico a la la red
justamente en la nube para que la
inteligencia artificial haga un
recorrido de toda esta información para
mejorar los sistemas de salud y va a
mejorar los sistemas de según esto en
realidad dice que sí que va a mejorar
mucho en tanto en cuanto a la gente y
las clínicas y los doctores participan
dicen aro
ese es uno de los objetivos y siempre
está la cuestión de la fiabilidad de los
datos y lo pongo eso en la nube no está
expuesto a que pase lo que pasa a diario
que es que la gente vaya va que la que
los hackers por ejemplo entre robert
información justamente esas son digamos
los pilares importantes para este
proyecto es que sea fiable y es tratar
con digamos en base al tiempo que la
gente se va dando cuenta que eso puede
mejorar primero desde el punto de vista
de la práctica médica y segundo desde el
punto de vista monetario el sistema de
salud en estados unidos solamente es
ahorraría
muchísimo dinero si todo esto si eso
beneficiaría a los estadounidenses y
sobre todo aquellos que no tienen los
medios para pagarse los costos de las
realidades están los privados es exacto
ese es uno de los objetivos que cuando
uno ofrezca que se pueda digamos
juntar toda esa información en pos de
toda la población que esté conectada con
este sistema de salud en realidad por
ejemplo en canadá hace un par de meses
atrás ya se conectaron todas las
farmacias el expediente médico que yo
tengo mi farmacia está conectado por a
cualquier farmacia accede al servicio
médico
haya abierto yo en cualquier otra
farmacia y eso se está empezando hace
poquito digamos que eso es en pequeña
escala y desde el punto de vista
farmacéutico y en este caso es a gran
escala y con todo el sistema de salud de
eeuu principalmente y después bueno al
mundo si es que esto sí que esto
prospera complicado las cosas pero
parece interesante si funciona porque
hay que ver no son nuevas tecnologías se
están probando puede ser pero yo
solamente quería decir que que canadá
tiene un lugar bastante interesante
bastante importante en términos de
inteligencia artificial y medicina hay
unidades de investigación en las
universidades canadienses
específicamente dedicadas a estudiar las
maneras en que la genética y que otros
tipos de cosas pueden ser analizados a
través de las máquinas inteligentes que
ellos llaman y que sean beneficiosas
para detectar más rápidamente las
posibilidades o las propensiones a tener
google hace 5 o 6 años atrás por un por
las búsquedas en el motor de búsquedas
de google el portal de google
uno sabía dónde se iba desplazando por
ejemplo un brote de sarampión porque la
gente cuando tiene los síntomas básicos
busca sarampión entonces las búsquedas
van incrementando por zonas entonces uno
va viendo cómo se va moviendo entonces
lo que en ese momento intento google era
determinar que en aquella zona que va
porque esto va subiendo en aquella zona
va a haber un brote en genética ahora
entonces a partir de una base de datos
genética de un grupo de personas pueden
determinar qué otro grupo de personas a
tener la misma enfermedad facilita las
muchas nuevas tecnologías leonor
jm ya no queda mucho tiempo entonces lo
que yo les estoy presentando es sobre el
tema de que lópez obrador quiere que
méxico deje de hacer el trabajo sucio de
eeuu y se está refiriendo a justamente
que es estados unidos el que más gente
de centroamérica expulsa y con violencia
a los centroamericanos que intentan
pasar hacia eeuu y ese fue un acuerdo
que
el actual presidente mexicano peña nieto
con obama habían negociado a cambio de
dinero para proteger toda esa zona
fronteriza entonces lo que lópez obrador
quieres que se termine de hacer ese
trabajo y centroamérica méxico
exactamente entonces pues y es un tema
candente en este momento sobre todo con
lo que está pasando en eeuu con los
inmigrantes centroamericanos ya antes de
irnos ya no nos queda más que un minuto
y medio dos minutos jm cuéntenos y me
cuesta decirle jm vamos a decir se
escribe jm el nuevo kms joven boca no
nos sentimos nos sentimos orgulloso en
parte por la participación de un
dominicano en las elecciones bueno las
elecciones cuando si en el proceso
electoral de méxico que es la del
expresidente laurent fernández como
encargado de la oea es también de los
observadores la misión sumamente bien
aquí hace pocos días
me llamó la atención fuimos a quebec
hemos andado mucho que en la ciudad no
lo principal era venir aquí
el segundo objetivo era familiar que era
visitar a mi hija que se va a mudar
precisamente este fin de semana cambia
de apartamento y tercer motivo el
festival de jazz de montreal
entonces se conjuga todo
y veo que voy a celebrar también aquí el
día de canadá el domingo de manera que
no me queda mucho tiempo porque me voy a
mediados del mes que viene y así estaré
visitando algunos museos estuve en la
ciudad de quebec en montreal donde va
además que queremos ir a ottawa
una buena época el lado de estados
unidos canadá del lado de acá nada
mínimo y fui visitamos varios varios
lugares más bueno a decir verdad nos
visitado canadá ya como cuatro veces
porque si mi hija vive aquí trabaja en
la uas y así en la organización
internacional exactamente entonces va a
cumplir un año y quisimos venir a
visitarle y como dijimos pues ayudarle
en la mudanza de julio se cambia todo el
mundo de castex es una ciudad que de
hecho es curioso que todo el mundo se
muda en una
fecha 30 y el día primero y eso ya no
hay a todo el día que se puede pasar
todo una vida en una casa ese orden a mí
me llama la atención y lo veo muy
positivo es muy muy bien pero son de las
cosas curiosas que uno ve acá en canadá
pues muy bien y de dígame en una palabra
la ciudad de québec que le gustó de
quebec bueno una palabra dije
[Risas]
bueno ya no nos queda más tiempo hoy se
nos fue terriblemente rápido pero yo
aceptó una invitación a nosotros en el
programa gracias a todos ustedes
nosotros y será hasta la próxima ya
todos